my name is John Stouffer and I'm a
photographer and a father
[Music]
being an artist in this Dana ages is
really exciting because with social
media you can put yourself out there and
get immediate feedback anymore I think
because I have a following an Instagram
it keeps me fresh because I'm always
wanting to create new content I'm
wanting to get out and shoot things that
are interesting around the city and just
consistently put out good quality images
that my followers would enjoy technology
has been awesome because you can take a
photo and see it right away and make
quick changes to what you just shot
where 20 years ago you had to wait for
your film to be developed I'm motivated
to create amazing pictures and images
because I see my friends and other
people I follow posting beautiful images
every day I can open my phone instead of
having to go to a gallery and be
inspired really what it boils down to
even if you're shooting specifically for
social media you should really focus on
creating that quality image that is true
to your style